françois costantini géopolitologue
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france comment expliquez vous ce
changement de pont la part du président
turc quel intérêt en toile de fond pour
rester un père noël bien le président
turc ont jour le présent turquie a été
demandé aux sept rencontres pour
plusieurs raisons je pense qu'il a
intérêt à une désescalade il se trouve
que les européens ont également intérêt
à reprendre lien avec le présent tueur
pour une la question essentielle des
migrants la turquie est quant à elle
sous asphyxie économique un sa monnaie a
suivi une très belle très grave
d'évaluation une paire de 2 20%
l'économie turque eux ne se porte pas
bien et on sait que la turquie a un
besoin vital d'exporter de tourisme
c'est une économie qui est par nature
ouverte
rappelons au passage que chaque année la
turquie face à l'ensemble de l'union
européenne réussie comme cette
performance d'avoir un excédent
commercial de près de 14 milliards de
dollars ce qui est c'est considérable
pourra marcher 80 millions d'habitants
face à aux marchés gigantesques et
qualitative de l'union européenne de 500
millions d'habitants donc en effet il ya
une question d'intérêt et le présent
turc a plutôt intérêt à ne pas se
détacher de l'union européenne d'autant
que l'union européenne a mis dans la
corbeille de réconciliation si on peut
dire le projet de modernisme au dernier
à sion pardon de l'union douanière avec
la turquie
quelles conditions bosse elle a apposé
pour cette reprise des échanges
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya des
conditions qui porte à l'attitude de la
turquie vis-à-vis de la grèce sur chypre
la grèce notamment la sur la grèce ni
européenne exige que la turquie arrêt
illégaux notamment avec le le navire ne
serait ce que qu'elles se mettent à la
table des négociations avec athènes
justement sur la définition du plateau
continental ce qui posera sa bande de
problème puisqu'on sait que la turquie
n'est notamment pas signataire de la
convention de montego bay de 1982 sur le
droit de la mer
donc ce qu'on veut en quelque sorte
c'est que la turquie reviennent à la
table des négociations est une attitude
attitude disons moins défiante à l'égard
de l'union européenne mais vous y croyez
vraiment ça tu appelles
mandat des relations entre les deux
parties notamment du côté de la partie
turque
non ça paraît dit il ya une divergence
d'intérêts a également et puis il faut
dire les choses c'est de façon globale
c'est pas une c'est une question
conjoncture est une question
structurelle
je pense que on a depuis plus de 15 ans
la la turquie l'union européenne négocie
sur l'adhésion
je pense que c'est une c'est une fausse
piste d'ailleurs pour deux ou plusieurs
raisons c'est qu'un la turquie n'a pas
une vocation européenne et que l'union
européenne n'a pas vocation à accueillir
turquie et que en effet la turquie n'est
pas dans une logique en tout cas une
europe and line prend aux logiques en
effet on voit aujourd'hui des influences
de puissance qui n'est pas celle qui qui
s'intégrera en quelque sorte dans un
club européen et je pense qu'il ya au
départ de la part de l'union européenne
à mon sens une une espèce de politique
ambiguë je pense qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de négocier la turquie pour
lui dire non à la fin il lui était
préféré à mon sens de dire non à la
turquie au départ et de s'engager dans
un véritable partenariat et non pas dans
une adhésion qui a peu de chances
d'aboutir et sur laquelle on continue je
pense que pour se mettre à la table des
négociations il faudra également avoir
des politiques claires de chaque côté y
compris de la part de l'union européenne
vis-à-vis de la turquie pour vous et
pour l'heure le président révèle encore
réellement un enjeu l'adhésion de la
turquie à l'union européenne
nature pour la turquie où il a turquie
auront aura intérêt à adhérer mais n'est
pas jouée dans une perspective sur plan
stratégique la nature qu'il n'est pas
dans dans une paire steve open ces
engagements sont essentiellement aux
chalands tôt notamment dans le monde
arabe on voit avec cette politique néo
ottomane avec cette politique d'être
influence en libye en syrie dans l'eau
dans le haut karabakh en effet on voit
que la turquie a en quelque sorte son
propre pré carré on voit pas en quelques
heures en quoi elles pourraient
s'intégrer en effet dans une heure les
visons diplomate d'une vision et
diplomatique européenne elle a intérêt
en effet resté proche de l'union
européenne pour plusieurs raisons
notamment au plan économique au plan au
plan financier
au plan commercial ou la turquie en
effet reste lié avec les économies de
l'union européenne déjà il faudra bien
joue pour lui pour l'union européenne
vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure c'est
la question migratoire une question
centrale c'est donc impossible aussi
pour bruxelles de ne pas discuter avec
ankara bien sûr en effet c'est bruxelles
en quelque sorte qui a donné en quelque
sorte le bâton et la baguette de chef
d'orchestre présent tueur c'est l'union
européenne qui organisait la bouillie de
submersion migratoire qui scella la
chancelière allemande qui a ouvert un
grand des portes à l'immigration
illégale
et quand on s'est aperçu de la
catastrophe eh bien on était allés
chercher le président turc est en effet
le présent turc a eu beau jurer fait
d'être en quelque sorte aujourd'hui le
décideur gardant des plusieurs millions
de syriens son territoire je rappelle
que la turquie accueille entre 3 et 4000
en c1 son territoire et qu'elle est
sensée à moyennant 1
l'une est déjà qu'elle a reçu 2 autour
de 6 milliards d'euros de garder les
laissais rien mais dans une limite je
rappelle que la caisse l'accueil
l'accord 10,1 pouces un négoce et de
façon unilatérale tanguay la marque elle
sans en référer à aux autres dirigeants
européens alors que l'allemagne était
même pas d'ailleurs n'est même pas dans
officiellement la la présence de l'union
européenne bien se limite à 72 mille
migrants on voit bien que cet accord est
faible et qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'union
européenne qui doit revoir sa politique
migratoire en quelque sorte qui a
constitué un appel d'air gigantesque et
on voit aujourd'hui en effet que
l'accueil de migrants illégaux continue
ce qui pose une question et c est ce qui
ne s il ne peut qu'augurer des tensions
avec la turquie d'ailleurs là-dessus
la turquie qui aident et être en
première ligne justement sur la sur la
question migratoire un tout dernier mot
concernant cet échange donc aujourd'hui
entre le président turc et les
présidents du conseil et de la
commission européenne il n'y aura pas de
conférence de presse commune à l'issue
des discussions est ce que ça vous
semble anecdotique ou alors au contraire
c'est assez révélateur des tensions qui
règnent est une reprise de contact en
quelque sorte et on sait que la la
reprise au contact pour autant n'augure
pas en effet ne une conférence une
conférence de presse ça veut dire qu'on
ait fait qu'aujourd'hui on va à mon avis
mettre sur la table les désaccords dans
un premier temps et puis ensuite se met
peut-être d'accord sur une
une feuille de route pour essayer de
régler dans la mesure du possible
l'ensemble de ces désaccords donc une
conférence de presse suppose un minimum
d'entente
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
uniquement dans une une première logique
une première étape 2 qui consiste à
renouer les fils sans plus merci
beaucoup pour votre regard françois
costantini
je rappelle que vous êtes géopolitologue